and Richard painter my surprise comedian
what's the basis of your groups lawsuit
against President Trump a lawsuit - it's
a lawsuit side of the table
yeah which which lawsuit against
President Trump is somebody on this
lawsuit brought by citizens for
responsibility and ethics in Washington
is about the money the president is
getting from foreign government yeah
that's that's actually illegal the
founders of our country figured that out
that foreign governments would like to
bribe other countries political leaders
because they were doing it all over
there in England the Parliament was
getting bought off by not only the king
of Great Britain but the English problem
is being bought off by the King of
France and so they figured you know we
don't want that going on here so they
have this provision in the Constitution
called the emoluments clause if they
drafted it in the 1970s when I was
growing up they would have called it
paola cause but it's the same idea that
nobody holding a position of Trustee the
United States government can receive
profits or benefits gifts internet from
foreign governments and that includes
companies controlled by foreign
governments believe the Bank of China
which is apparently loaning the Trump
Organization some money and I know a lot
of people say it's about the hotel rooms
in that part of it we talk about the
hotel rooms the diplomats run them out
and then they rent the ballroom they
have a big party and all the middle
eastern countries want to party at the
Trump Hotel and you go to Willard if you
want to meet Democrats but we think is
unconstitutional we gone into federal
court in New York and we're asking to
judge look this and most of all the
money the presidents
I didn't have you smoke pot but I'm
going to try tonight sir Jared Kushner
security clearance be revoked while he
is under investigation
yeah lose such a vital part of our
government anyone want to tack on that
one he is a busy man I have a
responsibility in the Middle East right
now he's back in the US we've actinic
said he saw it already it's in the world
it's in the works right I know it only
bigger but the question is will it and
it won't I mean the president lost his
right arm with Michael Flynn being gone
Jared Kushner's his left he's not going
to get his administration's becoming a
family business you know you know six
months from now it might be just you
know Donald and Ivanka and Jared and
that may be the entire administrative
reeben on a problem yeah is there no
legal way to take it away when
somebody's under investigation is it up
to the president it's up to the
president the legal way is to get rid of
the project
[Applause]
laughter imagine what responsibilities
do tech companies like Facebook and
Twitter have and policing online
extremism well there is a responsibility
at the British prime minister recently
announced to resume that she was going
to regulate the internet police the
internet I'm not so sure that's the
solution I think that there way possible
not yet not not it's not a solution no
it's not possible I think the way
forward is to encourage more counter
speech so Isis in other jobs more EU is
when I say I say more years yeah thank
you it's kind of you to say I myself but
that Isis and other jihadist groups are
active online they actually are ahead of
us you know way ahead of us when it
comes to online recruitment and the
propaganda videos are as we all know of
a quality that that is really affected
so we need to be both countering their
message online and producing so that's
counter narratives and also producing
alternative narratives online to really
get to those to those young people and
and gets them before Isis gets have you
seen evidence of that the work is at a
very nascent stage it's it's really sad
actually so much more needs to be done
and the tech companies are beginning to
invest in some of this Facebook has just
announced a measure where they're going
to be looking at some of this but they
are way behind in this stuff okay
Bradley are you hopeful that citizens
efforts on climate change can counteract
the Trump's administration's harmful
environmental policies yes actually I am
I've been working with a group called
citizens climate Lobby and they work in
a very interesting way they sort of
train you to talk to Republicans about
climate change it's kind of a
combination of like defcon5
marital therapy and you know how to work
with but there and heat like no sudden
movements
but it actually is it's it's exciting it
was it was really exciting to me
especially in these polarizing times
carlos Cabello in from florida 26
district is a republican are you should
to have on the show because their voices
are very powerful and what you do is
like it's so much it's fun to stand in
righteous indignation and scream at
somebody who's denying science to you
but it doesn't move the ball and it
actually makes it worse
so you find common ground and there's a
lot of economic common ground in dealing
with climate change there's tremendous
economic opportunity
corporations are actually they want
predictability they want us to deal with
it my frustration with these
corporations who say that they're upset
about pulling out of the Paris Accords
is they say they believe the climate
change is happening but they don't make
it a lobbying priority and we need to
call out these seemingly benevolent and
many of them are corporations and say if
you're saying that climate change is
happening if you're saying it is the
threat that it is you need to make it a
priority you're in power you got a lot
of money together you can beat the Koch
brothers all right final question I
think we're the best one answer this
what explains why the US stock market
continues to rise well look the
president inherited a relatively sound
economy we're continuing to add some
200,000 jobs each month nothing
catastrophic has happened in the world
be it it's sort of the site will talk
about cyberattacks but no terrorist
attacks no financial crisis yet interest
rates are relatively low so the market
continues to ride the way it does I mean
I think what's surprising is that we
expected to see massive sell-off
following Briggs that we expect you to
see sell-off following the election also
I always thought that the market hated
above all volatility we had mister
volatility in office I thought that
would
but apparently that was not Medicare no
we had one or two day blips where the
market would tank a couple of times but
but other than that the markets been
relatively dry weather gets a trump
bubble I think we'll look back on it
there's not enough fear usually when you
have a stock market that's rising this
fast there's a certain amount of anxiety
there that the absence of that fear
tells me that it's it's going to be
we're going to see it as a bubble at
something and there's also anticipation
remember of racks cut of all of his
plans laid out and that he ran on the
market is still anticipating that that
will come to fruition money rules
thank you everybody Thank You panel you
were terrific
[Applause]